السلطات الفرنسيه وضعت جانبا ما تمسكت به
لسنوات من اعتبارات اخلاقيه وعسكريه وقررت
احتضان مفهوم التسكع ولكن عسكريا فبعد
سنوات من التردد طائرات كميكازي بدون طيار
او المسيرات المتسعه كما تلقب ستدخل الجيش
الفرنسي فوفقا لصحيفه نموض الفرنسيه هذه
الطائره ستكون متعدده المحركات ومجهزه
بالعديد من المراوح قادره على حمل ما يصل
الى 35 كيلو جراما من المتفجرات او
الذخيره طائرات كميكاز او الطائرات
الانتحاريه هي نوع من انظمه الاسلحه
الجويه لكن لماذا تعرف باسم الذخيره
المتسكعه لان هذه الطائرات تحوم لبعض
الوقت فوق منطقه يتم تحديدها على انها هدف
محتمل وتضرب فقط بمجرد التعرف على العدو
تتميز بصغر وسهوله اطلاقها طبعا لكن
الميزه الرئيسيه لهذه الطائرات تكمن
بصعوبه اكتشافها ورصدها وامكانيه اطلاقها
من مسافات بعيده فهذه الطائرات تشبه الى
حد كبير صواريخ كروس التي تضرب اهدافا على
بعد مئات الكيلومترات لكنها بديل ارخص
ثمنا واسهل بالتحكم وفي وقت تعود فيه طبعا
المسيرات العسكريه تقليديه الاكبر والاسرع
الى قواعدها بعد اسقاط ما تحمله من صواريخ
كميكازي تصطدم بهدفها لتنفجر فيه فيما بعد
[موسيقى]